كوابيس خسائر المعارك لا تثني احلام بوتين
الطمح لحسم المعركه لصالحه رغم التداعيات
الصعبه التي اثقلت كاهل الحكومه الروسيه
وعمقت الازمه الديموغرافيه في البلاد
تداعيات جاءت تباعا واثرت بالدرجه الاولى
على الاقتصاد الروسي والنمو الديموغرافي
الذي بات يسير بمعدلات بطيئه جدا رغم
التحفيزات الماليه التي قدمها بوتين
للعائلات التي تنجب الاطفال
فالاستراتيجيات التي لجا اليها الرئيس
الروسي في الفتره الاخيره ابرزها التعبئه
العسكريه ادت الى نقص فادح في سوق العمل
وفرار اكثر الفئات تحصيلا علميا خارج
البلاد وسط مخاوف كبيره من ان الازمه
الديموغرافيه التي تمر بها روسيا والتي
باتت تشكل تهديدا لكل جوانب الحياه قد
تؤدي الى انكماش سكاني في السنوات المقبله
وضعف اقتصادي سببه نقص الفادح في الايدي
العام الشابه القادره على الانخراط في
العمليه الانتاجيه الاقتصاديه حيث اظهرت
دراسه اجرتها المدرسه العليا للاقتصاد ان
روسيا في حاجه الى استقبال ما بين 390
الفا ومليون ومائه الف مهاجر كل عام حتى
نهايه القرن لتجنب انكماش سكاني وشيك وفق
مراقبين فان الازمه الديموغرافيه التي
تشهدها روسيا تفاقمت بعد الخسائر التي
سببتها الحرب الدائره في اوكرانيا التي
ادت لمقتل العشرات من الجنود وبالدرجه
الاولى جائحه كورونا التي ضربت روسيا بشده
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات